um why don't we
check in here
with brian from phoenix brian you're on
the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
i was listening to one of your recent
episodes regarding the kyle rittenhouse
shooting you were talking about uh how
it's representative of all of the uh the
problems with gun culture
and um you know the
uh the fact that kyron house felt
justified in going there at all is sort
of indicative of all of those issues
yes parenting gun culture vigilantism
etc
would you um you know
i actually i agree with a lot of that
would you also say that there's a
similar issue with the way that um
many of the protesters felt justified in
being there around like the uh
particulars around the jacob lake
shooting um in terms of
you know is there any onus on the media
that portrayed the shooting in the way
that it did given um you know what we
know about it now that you know the
what was occurring before the police got
there the kids in the car the knife and
the seat all of those things those are
there's kind of two questions there and
i think it's important to be really
careful the protesters to the extent
that people were protesting i'm not
talking about looting arson or anything
like that that stuff's against the law
and i'm against it but
the protesting and marching and holding
signs and saying things
um
constitutionally protected
paramount uh element of the united
states of america right that that's
that is beyond reproach as long as
you're doing it in a non-violent way
the second part is were they
ginned up into a frothy state
because of media coverage which could
have been different
that is totally plausible i don't
remember
the coverage now and i'm i you know i
would need to study it more it's
completely plausible that media could
bear a responsibility
for raising tensions i'm not saying they
did i'm just saying it's theoretically
possible but that's a different issue
from the pro i don't think we could say
that there's a problem with a culture
where people feel like it's okay to go
and protest that it is okay to go and
protest and we want to be really clear
about that
definitely yeah thanks for tuning in all
right brian thank you so much for the
call that's going to do it for calls
today i do plan and hope to take more
calls again soon and i will speak to you
then